There will be due dates to help you stay on track. The summer course is on a
condensed schedule. We will be covering 15 weeks of content in ten weeks, so
keeping up is vital. There is a draft version and a final version of each
problem set. There are three main exercises due on Wednesday, and a draft
version due on the Sunday before. The draft will help you start thinking about
the problems, so you can ask questions early. There will also be about 20 short
problems due with the final version of the problem set. Problem sets are always
due at 11:55 p.m. U.S. Pacific time. You can work ahead. We especially
recommend this if you have travel plans. We cannot accept late problem sets.
It's important that we post the solutions shortly after the due date and it is
not fair to accept work after the solutions are put up.